und nun aber zufolge 714 unserer
beliebten heute-show jährige warum ist
an die scheuer eigentlich noch im amt
heute verraten meine damen und herren
weil egal wer im moment aus dem kabinett
fliegt wissen sie wer drei sekunden
später durch die tür kommt ja fritze
märz und das kann nun wirklich keiner
wollen die paar wochen hatten wir jetzt
auch noch durch mit dem an die gerade
kamera aus er hat 2009 10 knapp 49
millionen euro für berater ausgegeben
angesichts seiner performance wer bitte
kann diese berater
das würde erklären ja die sind von der
agentur ernst & young also das sind
ernst & young
heuer hat jedenfalls noch viel vor jetzt
hat er zum beispiel ein gesetz ins
kabinett eingebracht das autonomes
fahren in ausgewählten zonen schon ab
nächstem jahr bei uns möglich macht
saubere technik made in germany
guck mal mama freihändig zauberei wenig
überraschend enthält andys gesetzentwurf
neben magie noch allerlei mängel und
lehrstellen haftungsfragen zum beispiel
ganz wichtig wer ist schuld wenn das
selbst fahrende auto ganz alleine den
hund meines nachbarn über fährt der
hersteller die software der hund noch
weiß das keiner
autonomes fahren könnte aber tatsächlich
die zukunft sein
stichwort mobilität auf dem land und
natürlich ist das erst der anfang
ingenieure arbeiten schon am autonomen
bobbycar während die faulen kinder
drinnen zocken fährt das teil völlig
autonom draußen rum
gerade bei dem wetter ist das viel
gesünder ich privat träume vom autonomen
rennrad über das nur am rande
in umfragen ist eine große mehrheit der
deutschen bei dem thema insgesamt sehr
sehr skeptisch wir misstrauen der
technik und halten uns selbst für die
besten autofahrer der welt ja klar was
wir im verkehr leisten
wie sollen das so seelenlose maschinen
jemals schaffen besoffen fahren zum
beispiel in der kurve überholen am hang
stinkefinger zeigen es können die nichts
können nur wir übrigens ganz autonom
wird das fahren erst mal sowieso nicht
es muss immer noch ein mensch dabei sein
der im ernstfall übernimmt und das ist
wahrscheinlich auch besser
angesichts dieser bilder hinter einem
parkenden auto kommt gleich eine
fußgängergruppe hervor kommt das auto
rechtzeitig zu stehen
ich weiß nicht war das jetzt gut hat er
bestanden
was übrigens auch noch dringend zu
klären wäre bevor das hier alles autonom
wird ist die sache mit dem datenschutz
schon heute wissen manche leute gar
nicht sind viele autos echte datenkraken
spionieren ihre besitzer aus senden
ständig gps daten an ihre hersteller der
tesla zum beispiel filmt seine umgebung
und den autoinnenraum selbst wenn er
parkt also offene fragen beim
datenschutz und dennoch ist das autonome
fahren an sich und jetzt sage ich was da
explodiert erfasst der kopf ein fast
schon sinnvolles projekt von andy
scheuer nur halt geklaut bei david
hasselhoff habe sämtliche daten wagen
durchsucht aber ich finde kein unfähigen
verkehrsminister alex tobin und wie viel
geld hast du noch mal für berater
ausgegeben alter sogar die ktz bemüht
sich über dich und hör auf den link
hatte befummeln bis zu verwerfen so
endstation
hier brennt wartet der maut
untersuchungsausschuss viel spaß
neu bei rtl mittweida
guck ich dort volkswagen will
automatisiertes fahren übrigens
schneller anbieten als die konkurrenz
und arbeitet deswegen jetzt mit
microsoft ja sie haben richtig gehört vw
mit bill gates dem erzfeind aller
verschwörungs hongs die ersten wehren
sich schon bei youtube das automagazin
zu den querdenker
jetzt ist es soweit vw und microsoft tun
sich zusammen
die beiden bösesten konzerne der welt
schlimmer als der hitler stalin pakt
aufwachen ihr schlaf schafe bill gates
trinkt blut von gefolterten kindern um
ewige jugend zu erlangen und volkswagen
ich weiß gar nicht ob man die bilder
zeigen kann hat den vw up design merkt
ein kleiner was geht sobald ich mir so
eine moderne karre kaufe bin ich doch
schon in der gates falle da ist doch
längst lateinische microsoft technik
navigation war nicht zum bahnhof alles
klar
nein nicht ins zentrum zum bahnhof
[Musik]
wer dem nicht du machst es nur schlimmer
was ist denn jetzt greift mal ins
handschuhfach da liegt die
bedienungsanleitung
herzlichen glückwunsch du bist geimpft
[Musik]
ich gehe zu fuß weiter das auto hat mich
wahrscheinlich gechipt hallo auto
ich bin mir sicher nicht mal zu hause
[Musik]
mein auto weiß wo ich wohne
woher die wahrheit fährt irgendwo da
draußen
bill gates hat gesagt er will die
menschheit auf 500 millionen reduzieren
kann man im netz nachrecherchieren das
sind alles erfundene tatsachen und jetzt
wissen wir auch wir uns umbringen will
mit autonomen autos und wenn wir nicht
höllisch aufpassen
[Musik]
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten
einfach anklicken märz gut los los du
scheiße fährt